[Musique]
ce gamin ne se croyait pas à la hauteur
j'ai cru que c'était seulement la peur
alors gelé pris sous mon aile
il avait raison d'avoir peur
dans l'art bord est l'échec le plus
important des services secrets
de notre histoire ça ne peut plus se
reproduire
rectifier ça
on a au moins certains qui veulent se
battre
les japonais prépare quelque chose de
plus grand et quelle est la cible on
pense que c'est bidon et washington
n'est pas d'accord
washington se trompe si on perd
les japonais envahiront la côte ouest
seattle san francisco los angeles
[Musique]
seront réduits en cendre
nous avons entre d'attaqué il faut
frapper un grand coup qui se rendent
bien compte de ce que ça fait
[Musique]
de douzaine d'avions
contre toute la flotte japonaise
ça n'est pas un combat équitable
je ne sais pas comment guider ces arabes
il se suivront jusqu'au bout
tu sais que tu as fait ce qu'il fallait
quand les autres compter sur toi
tu pourras tout affronter